well so many here in las vegas are still
dealing with the fallout from a year of
lost jobs and financial hardships but as
our economy bouncing back from the cobit
pandemic a lot of people are making
their way back to the workforce
sasha lofta shares tips to break into
your industry in what is a special
report
cooking is my passion and that's what i
do
after years away from the workforce
nicotis dixon just scored a job
in las vegas i was able to get what i
want
here and quickly she was hired at
arizona charlie's
and calls this position a blessing for
she
and her son mj it was just such a
lifesaver to know that we could
easily you know go and apply find jobs
you know have resources look out for us
nakotas is one of many who searched for
work here in southern nevada
after a long time out of the loop i
think a lot of people are in this
interesting place where they're
definitely wanting to go back to work
sonya pedowitch owns taurian consulting
a group that works to fill
i.t and tech jobs across the valley she
says
if you're trying for a particular
position it's more important than ever
to prepare
just in general have you been keeping up
on talking about what you've learned
talking about what experiences you have
before you throw your hat in the ring
pedowitch recommends keeping your skills
fresh with seminars
online courses and up-to-date industry
changes
if you haven't been in that working
environment how have you stayed in that
playground as far as talking about this
is who i am
these are the skills i bring to the
table interview skills are also
a must sonya says it's essential to know
your stuff
and be ready to ward off any nerves how
do you stay
in that arena without getting nervous
and being able to sell yourself as
someone who should be brought back to
the workforce and above anything
attitude is key though some may use the
term
overqualified pedowitch encourages you
to use that expertise
for all it's worth if you want to use
your master's degree
or use your years of experience or use
your title
to the advantage of bettering an
organization or bettering a team then
you're an asset to an organization
as for nakotas she calls persistence key
in any professional situation reach out
that's what people need to do
you know more instead of just like he
said you know
just waiting on someone to call you
reach out that's what i did
and says her whole family is grateful to
kick start
a new chapter here in nevada this is a
wonderful place to start over and that's
what we're doing
sasha loftis 8 news now all this week
we're taking a deeper look at the
numbers of problems the pandemic did
create from hiring to older workers
retraining adapting to remote work
and also hot jobs post pandemic we're
bringing you those stories right here
on 8 news now